it's a beautiful day because it's
another day in my hand crappy never
stopping
oh no she couldn't keep please never
stop
what's up idea Birds how you doing a kid
bird one IKEA bird - what's poppin
first of all shame on you shame on
everyone for speaking ill of my
beautiful building everyone's saying oh
it looks like kangaroo you know I read
the comments and I was like wait there's
kangaroos in Minecraft that's awesome
and I realize you were we're pointing to
my tribute statue statue to my bed horse
uragan I try to fix it as best as I
could to make it look like a horse
if anyone comments that it looks like a
kangaroo you're gonna be instantly
banned okay this is for yard again this
is a beautiful memorial and it needs to
be respected thank you now that we have
that out of the way today we have a lot
of stuff funny stuff to do do god
there's just like I've been playing
already today for like four hours
listen I had to get diamonds that was
poor okay I've also been breeding the
army of pigs that's right
politicians worldwide are shaking they
know that we have an army ready to
strike at any moment oh god they're
pushing me stop pushing me I'm getting
something they're getting violent
God once you get going it just it gets a
bit crazy where we're not ready
we're not yet already yet one thing
actually there's one thing I wanted to
do really quick I didn't do it because I
know you guys would get salty and be
like he's playing so much with powders
hey we're just event by the way did
their bone have you seen spent loma
Lomas have you seen Sven Sven hello have
you seen have you seen Sven back off
back off 360 back off no don't blow it
there we go I swear I heard him sin it's
you they are barking so they they must
been here Sven your God is he trapped
again spent oh look at him he looks like
it's crying so mad I'm sorry he's crying
tears I told you stay away from sheeps
how do you even get there how do you
even
even Stephens many plebian spent go what
is happening there it is your free Spain
no he goes back in then you will never
be what their sheep stop it come here
come here
stop it's like no wait where is this
going
smelly's hey hey it's all right don't
worry IKEA Birds it's fine he's safe I
also made it so it's a pressure plate
now so when's the end there it's pretty
cool
I love it I I haven't done anything with
the war yet but I wanted to not be
sidetracked for two seconds my gosh
all right Lomas uh no he doesn't want to
oh he's already on a leash no no no you
stay we're building the tower of llama
it's very popular this time of year
what do you never visited Tower of llama
[Music]
now get up get up oh my god they're
gonna die our thing this is your new
home welcome to your new home there you
go here you go buddy enjoy enjoy you're
here you're here forever you're part of
something greater now this works so well
before what is he doing stop I'm like
this is not what I wanna hit what does
she do something all right I'm gonna
need you guys to did he die you are
going to the Tower of sheep yeah Tower
sheep that's nice
this is your home enjoy dummy you're a
dumb dumb oh yeah
Tower of what they're sheep if you guys
ever come visit my server you gotta come
see the tower of of what their sheep
it's great this time of year I got I got
a sake all right so now bing bang bong
there you go you want health care we got
them all right
let's join power of Watership and you
will get all special privileges you're
against you're against the tower of
Watership animal abuse sir
swen don't make me put you on water she
power I will if I have to no one will
stand between me and my love for water
sheep come here I don't care you're
going on power you are going on tower of
water I have actual stuff to do this
episode by the way don't I just need to
do this before you are coming I don't
care about your relatives being lost
what is wrong with me what is this
fiction come honestly why is he fighting
me so much you should be grateful this
is an honor and a privilege and you know
it what school where is he going he just
ran back do you love him that much are
you in love with him that's so romantic
ISM they belong to each other
that is so cute oh my god what am I
looking at what is that is that a
chicken oh sorry I don't feel so judged
listen don't judge me this has to be
done I don't care about your feeling
I really don't
llamas don't have feelings oh my god
what am i doing I know you guys belong
together so you'll be next to each other
[Laughter]
back no okay we're gonna have to do it
like this we got to cut off that ah I'm
a dummy damn I keep looking over and I
think the pigs are like sakura trees and
i'm like what there's Sakura blossom and
in Minecraft so it turns out they're
kind of an inseparable well that's a
weird he just disappeared that's so lame
that he just left you all alone if you
just left it like I thought you guys
were friends how that's so sad
that's so sad that your own friend left
you I really feel for you gosh 10
million views baby this series gets 10
million viewers
it's beautiful
the thing is like they keep spawning and
I never know what to do with them
now this is like eco-friendly because
I'm I'm using them for a good purpose
right what they're sheep this man is so
shocked he can't even look at me he's
never seen anything like this in his
life okay so as you can see here I'm
clearly having a problem with having to
constantly growing more potatoes I think
it's time we fixed that because I'm
gonna need this army to become stronger
okay so and look away just for one
second puppy needs to do taxes
I feel awful is the worst oh boy
accounting sure is hard am i right Sven
okay there's one thing actually I will
do before we do all this stuff at base
because everyone will get bored if I'd
to stay here all the time
lie SEPA sewed I spent a lot of money
and a lot of time to try and get a
conduit to work it didn't work all right
let's try and place the conduit
Wow that is so cool Wow guys right and
then I got all the comments telling me
how to use it so conduit I still don't
really get any like prismarine rocks a
peepee poo-poo oh god how am I gonna
find him has anyone seen peepee poo-poo
no you're not peeing you're not people
if we I can tell I can tell the
difference between fake people for in
real people poop okay can the real
peepee poo-poo please stand up maybe
there you are people book Oh perfect
perfect stay here I need people pop oh
and no one else oh my gosh
stop pushing I need TP when we're gonna
kill so you can summon the wither in
Minecraft which it's like this boss
that's what we're using the army for all
right people you're free oh my gosh look
at his help pp are you okay
how do you heal his help he peep who's
gonna die
how to heal Pig mine crash don't fall
down there people boo he's just very
loyal oh I have the potato in my hand I
was like he's actually loves me
oh I still have some night vision and I
still have some water breathing okay
sure I think we are just the melon okay
so then I'm heading out look after Tower
Obama you're low on health people poopoo
you think it's unsafe to go and unwise
you know who's unsafe and unwise people
you are okay
get in the boat don't ever speak to me
like that again you know you're not even
a real pig that's right you're a
Minecraft Pig so we're heading back to
the water monument because I want to try
and activate the conduit and you'd be
quiet'
all right I want none of your typical PP
oh my gosh let me speak oh I forgot that
food are you kidding me so I don't know
if this is correct but if I add
gunpowder no does this work it's working
okay now it's splash healing all right
peepee poo-poo
I'm only doing this because I know the
nine year olds I'm gonna be like oh how
do I splice you wow that's so cool how
do I activate it I was trying to heal
him I mean pay those that baby people
was uh you like that let me write oh
yeah your name is peepee poo-poo we're
gonna beat the ender dragon together
p-people is gonna live forever
peepee poo-poo will never die
put this on what's your name its baby
Bobo idiot
everyone knows people has two lives
everyone knows that it's the second rule
of Minecraft who created it not how many
lives does people hope I have two
everyone knows that
beeping poop what was your dad who I
lost my dad Wow grow up peepee poo-poo
to pee pee to poop
yeah how you like them apples oh it
lifts up that's perfect okay so we'll
find it easily then notice
second of all we got to get a bunch of
prismarine which we can get in the water
monument which I dread going back to
because I freakin died
oh my god people would know oh oh that
was close PP foo there it is damn it
it's far away dude wait there's two
right next to each other see sayonara
peepee poo-poo son so I should be able
to just like oh god I hate I hate this I
hate that I hate it it's the night
vision as well so apparently you can use
sponges too like damn there's so many oh
this is nice Oh perfect you can use
sponges to peepee poo-poo
dude there's another island over there
another MooMoo Island another Momo
island let's go people another city
oh my god I'm finding all this stuff
we're gonna we make a new friend people
can I steal you guys cuz I need you for
like a certain thing trust me you're
gonna like it
is that a freaking roller coaster what
is that
stop complaining isn't this like damn
it's so cool when you have a night
vision I need you to not follow me down
okay is that all right cool what do we
got mending that's really good
cursor vanishing that's what your dad
has no one's ever made that joke oh
sorry
just get up just get up in your lip okay
cool
why does everyone I love die what is
this curse people who will oh there's
another fort over that damn I'm finding
so much stuff I can I'm what's this
supposed to be a quick in-and-out
there's another underwater monument
there are you kidding me
what is this seed man wait there people
poo poo okay clearly you guys are you
guys are friends that's fine
oh you're against me you're standing up
against me okay we'll see you bad day so
apparently enemies can't spawn on these
islands oh damn
[Music]
but the moo moo cows can and apparently
you can be quiet you can use their soup
or something like that and then make
soupy doopy I'm bringing one of you back
home because you're super rare look so
there's a little bit of green there and
that means now I said you're coming with
me did you not hear me I love that
mushroom island just like one island one
mushroom so sorry it's like it because I
set their distance a lot higher but
that's why I kept finding stuff I'm like
whoa I can see so far damn I love
Minecraft I'm totally wasting my
underwater breathing right now but I
just realize I'm not gonna have space to
bring back everyone look at that another
underwater monitor man dude look how
cool that is
that is so doe
if only peepee poo-poo came with me on
this what is on top of that Tower
I'm finding so many awesome stuff what
look they built little pumpkin things
don't think so
don't shoot me I have baby in my hand oh
no he fell for the old baby in hand
trick what is this what the Frick is
this low-key kind of cute don't shoot I
have baby carrots and potatoes I take
the arrows the rest can go slick itself
so what do I do with this dough just
throw oh my gosh did you not see I have
baby all right you guys are coming with
me
[Music]
okay we'll definitely come back to
explore the ice mountains
maybe there's Eskimos in Minecraft
there's Eskimo is there an arrow in my
frickin head it's fine
peepee poo-poo wouldn't complain so
neither shall i okay so apparently I'm
finding every single water monument in
the whole world oh my gosh I got so
distracted I forgot why we're even here
the conduit that's right thank you for
reminding me sure brought doors for this
because I need to place I just need to
place them around it could that be it
just like a circle around it oh my gosh
you enjoying the weather
yeah bit hot isn't it think this should
do it Sim salabim it worked everyone it
worked wow so cool thanks Felix why
aren't you looking at me okay so there
there there there and then there there
nope
oh I think I did it
whoa okay we gotta be careful I know if
you go whoa I guess underwater vision
were they oh my god that's so awesome
gosh if I knew I would have placed an
extern water heart in the head is it
sucking me so I think it makes it
becomes more be quite dolphin I don't
need you I have conduit so top layer
just goes across and the bottom one same
thing
man if uragan could see this he'd be so
amazed
jörgen loved conduits what's his
favorite thing I assume the same pattern
okay so now it should be maxed out we
can swim around here without any problem
no Porsche is required baby you guys got
so angry oh my god you were actually
right I'm so sorry coal enchanted
fishing rod man I guess I can't move the
conduit can i ah god that sucks
it'd be so good to have that next to all
right well that's cool anyway now we
know how it works and I won't make the
same dumb mistakes again there's
literally a woman ocean monument next to
my spawn oh hey look people poop I made
it back as well that's awesome so
apparently mending pens is really good
because once you get XP you heal the
pants you can heal your pants just like
I healed the peepee poo-poo with a
splash potion just like I did that thing
that I did
if you remember I am I here all right we
have the guardians of the peepee poo-poo
yeah they're so cute okay so since I
know this is kind of boring I know but I
love it so I don't care
redstone time it's time for me to
finally finalize my farm which I
actually I actually worked a lot on it
and I'm really quite happy with it the
plan was that I was gonna have a farm
that is automated just by one click of a
button and that's that has been the real
challenge I think to make it all work
seaming Leslie yes that's a word so I'll
show you actually you know what I
haven't finished it yet so the problem
right now is that water runs down here
and it ruins all my stuff so there's
pumpkins growing here so I was gonna put
melon growing here hopefully there's
enough space can I just do this it's
gonna have to go like that one two three
okay this might be a little tight but if
it works it will be very very smacking
smacking it's a Swedish word smacking
you never heard all right it's big brain
time so I need how many Pistons yeah
eight I need eight Pistons I can never
seem to have enough Pistons I made a I
made eight okay perfect okay I really
hope this works it's gonna be truly
truly epic and I'll explain oh excuse me
the geniusness of my contractions you
know those things your mom has I need
dirt apparently I can think more than
one step ahead Oh
all right so we're just gonna copy this
side basically so look I made a little
window it's kind of cool
it is more complicated you think because
the water has to touch it on the under
underneath but here on the pumpkins and
melons it doesn't have to so it's it is
kind of cool I you can look at okay it's
cool I thought it was cool it was hard
and then there will go this over here
what you are for I don't know I hope
you're not important and then we'll put
this here the water will run here I
think yes fortunately I can't oh wait
maybe if I can axe it on this side
that'd be nice
ok cool haha just looking at them ok so
I need what do I need melons do I have
it because I need just a few seeds ok so
now we're here we are gonna plant plant
the plant plant the plant plant the
plant plant plant I have water on me
perfect the water will run here that's
so good Felix no no no no
coal's I need to do that eight times
epic just drop it from here okay cool I
can just grab it from here my gosh I'm
so big brain that sometimes I make small
brain decisions that's a true testimony
of big brain there we go
now we plant melon melon Xiang Xiang
need edlin almost raises celery stop
rhyming Felix you are not making
anything better n okay so cool out so
they should just work so I'll just I'll
this assume they'll work so what's
happening down here Felix let me explain
Oh God let's see if I remember how I
have to I have to pay some like this
basically when I press the button it
sends out a pulse but I need that pulse
to be a little stronger let me test this
do I not have any sticks I'll test it
with this so you see here when I remove
it it holds it a little longer
it's fades and there you go because I
need the water to run through I'll show
you later I need the water to properly
run through so it puts all this stuff in
there in the box it will all make sense
for small brains don't worry
damn the space could not have been any
more perfect what did I already put the
wiring thanks Pierce from the past and
then the hopper needs to be connect and
you can tell it's going in the chest
because the little knob is pointing
towards it just like real life
with girls that was a sexy joke okay now
the only thing remaining man I'm so
excited it's to put the water in all the
holes and just pray to God that this
works so now we have fully automated
farm watch it run through it
you don't know how good that feels I
probably spend look it all went in here
all the melons all of them but let me
show you how it works it's pretty
awesome
no one cares Felix okay we're cool I'm
gonna tell it anyway so when you press a
button it only says it sends like a
signal right that's all it does but you
can tell them to Pistons in the back
please go up right away but the Pistons
in the back water flows through longer
so that all the taters properly go in
some Mis it's fine it doesn't really
matter and I did that here so this is
another this this extends to signal and
make sure the water throne runs through
longer and they'd does the exact same
thing on the pumpkins but not for the
water but for but for the Pistons
lifting it up because as you can tell if
now the Pistons are staying up waiting
for the water to run through then the
water goes down because otherwise the
water would just run away everywhere and
ruin my beautiful contraption piston
stays up what is done it goes down so
basically very big brain so now I can
farm all the taters to feed my army
great it looks like my camera stopped
working for some reason look at that
beautiful and now look at all those
taters my army keep feeding my children
that's right
I need you bigger I need you stronger
next episode we're gonna take on one of
the bosses of minecraft the wither but
I'm not afraid because I have the army
of pee pee poopoo together we are strong
feed my children
[Music]
anyway guys hope you enjoyed this
episode Sven did you have fun okay cool
okay DJ moo moo cow hit it oh yeah
thanks for watching another episode of
hope you guys enjoyed oh he goes on top
he's crazy
smash like check out the March and I see
you epic gamers next time also I added
this video I hope you enjoyed the dig
beragon
[Music]